this is the monduo 14-inch Pro Duo
display and it is incredible in February
I covered the 16 inch version and that
was so good that even MKBHD showed it
off in an unsponsored video saying that
he really likes it and back then David
actually sent me that 16 inch version
without me knowing and when I unboxed it
I was really surprised but now they are
back with the 14 inch version of it but
it is better in almost every single way
let's go ahead and open this thing up
and as you guys could see the packaging
is really nice even better than before
and look at that right there the
previous one was built with high quality
plastic but this thing is made out of
aluminum now I've looked at and tested
multiple different external displays but
they all have some very common problems
that monduo has addressed and pulling
this thing out and getting my first
impressions here
my goodness this is even better than
what David said it was going to be like
look at the panels right there how thin
they are and all of these outsides are
super high quality I'm gonna grab my 14
inch right there look at that guys you
have aluminum on both and wow now of
course we have a few plastic pieces in
here because they need to be plastic but
I'm really impressed by how thin and
flush this thing closes down let's go
ahead and slide it out like this and I
can go ahead and flip out one of the
displays right there let's go ahead and
flip the other one out and there you
have that Center Point which expands to
be able to fit onto your computer now
not only will this work with Mac but it
also works with Windows as well I'll go
ahead and set the down right here and
let's see what else is in the box so we
have an assortment of cables because
that's basically all you need you don't
need to have an external power brick or
anything like that we have a USB type-c
cable and we have another one this is
for power only if you want to feed the
display power and pass through to your
Mac which you can actually pass through
a hundred watts to keep your MacBook all
charged up here we have an HDMI cable
and then we have two USB type-c cables
right here as well now like I said with
the previous 16 inch version I was
skeptical I thought it'd be really bulky
that it would take a long time set up
and it genuinely wouldn't be that useful
but like I showed you guys in the
Florida trip it was amazing it easily
packed into my bag and I was able to get
it out and set it up in under 40 seconds
it was quick it was simple it was easy
and it allowed me to do video editing on
the go while having screens on the side
to show my media to be able to pull up
info online without having to go switch
between different programs it just
really sped up the whole workflow and it
was great overall but this one they made
it better in a lot of ways the first I
want to point out is instead of having
the USB connections on the bottom now it
is on the back of the main portion that
goes behind your screen this makes a
little bit easier to connect it and you
no longer have to have right angle
adapters or anything like that just your
simple two cables now I also mentioned
that whenever I traveled I would always
take the 16 inch because I wanted the
larger screen size compared to a 13 inch
MacBook or a 14 inch because a 14 inch
just wasn't enough space to do serious
in-depth video editing in other their
work and at the end I mentioned that I
can't wait for a 14 inch version because
with the extra displays on the side I
don't have to pack the biggest laptop
and I think they succeeded but way
better than I expected so let's go ahead
and I'll show you how easy it is to set
up bam I just folded this out let me go
ahead and extend it it is on there and
now I'm gonna grab this little hinge
which they actually upgraded it's
aluminum they made it a lot more stiff
and my screen setup is set up lastly
I'll plug in these two cables right here
and now that it's at the back it's a lot
easier
plugged in and we are on that is how
easy it is to connect your displays get
it attached like this and then just like
that let me show you guys how to
disconnect it actually undo that
bam I'll go ahead and fold down this
screen the second one unplug the cables
and you can go ahead and toss this into
your bag and head out and wherever you
go for example a coffee shop you can
have a slim package that triples your
displays and be able to have optimal
productivity with triple screens without
taking up a bunch of room with this new
14 inch setup now that is cool all on
its own but what is very special is how
the mondu stands out from everything
else this thing has a 2560 by 1600
resolution so it is ultra sharp but what
really matters along with that is the
software and I'll get into that in just
a bit the displays are 14 inch and they
are designed to match the MacBook they
have a high 144 Hertz refresh rate which
means that they are super smooth just
like your Mac and with that they have
500 nits of brightness which perfectly
matches the macbook's brightness in
normal modes it has DirectX support and
100 DCI P3 color gamut so the same color
accuracy as your Mac and it has a very
low latency built in as well and
compared to the 16 inch model that you
guys could still buy this actually has a
glass display panel instead of plastic
so it is designed to perfectly match
your MacBook and in the comments to my
original video for the 16 inch a lot of
you guys really praised how you liked
this setup that you stop using an iPad
on the side because of latency and just
how well it worked together with the
monduo software and another person said
that they bought cheaper alternatives
and the screen was just fuzzy and not
enjoyable able to use in this setup was
way better and now with a 14 inch model
being out it is even better with its
aluminum design and improved kickstand
and everybody that has a 14 inch Mac
that loves portability but sometimes
needs extra screen real estate just like
I do well you guys can Rejoice now I
want to show you guys the software which
makes this a complete product as you
guys saw both displays are working out
of the box there's no Hoops to jump
through weird workarounds but I'm going
to go ahead and download the soft right
here and then we are going to open it up
this is what makes these so amazing I'm
gonna install the drivers that are going
to optimize this whole setup and make it
just like a Mac and just like that the
displays have automatically been
arranged the resolution has been
automatically adjusted to match your Mac
the same thing with the UI scaling and
even in with auto brightness so if you
guys look right here I'm going to turn
down the brightness and all of the
displays match up in terms of brightness
which is awesome the same thing goes
with the colors of the displays they
also match up perfectly which is why if
Apple were to make an external display
setup this is what they would make and
David who is a huge Mac fan he created
this for his own needs and he wanted to
be apple quality like now let me show
you guys the settings right here we have
a few different options I can mention
you can match the brightness of the
displays and with that we are going to
match the resolution we're going to
automatically arrange them so they just
work there's no menus or extra buttons
to Fumble around with and try to
optimize and this is not enabled by
default but you can turn off them onto a
backlighting on full dimming if you guys
notice when I dimmed it last time when
my Mac display turned off the other ones
did not but with that setting bam they
are going to match up and turn on and
off all together now we can have the app
automatically launch we have updates and
then as far as displays you can actually
disable certain things if you don't want
it there's also some advanced settings
here so you can combine everything and
we have a few other settings if you want
to customize how your app is set up now
with that we can go into the menu bar
right here and if you want to make some
adjustments yourself you can actually go
in and adjust brightness if you want to
adjust the contrast some other changes
and you can do some Hardware level
adjustments as well so you still have
full control all built in easily into
the software but the beauty of this
setup is that you don't have to you have
this crazy triple setup no matter where
you go if you're traveling you're in a
hotel room going from your homework
space to maybe an office if you're
returning to work while maximizing your
screen real estate in a super small
package which is super easy to use in
extremely high quality so if you guys
have been looking for a solution like
this or if you bought some cheap setup
that's super plasticky that doesn't
match up with low brightness low color
accuracy the displays are fuzzy and you
want to get something better this is the
way to do it you guys can check out
their excellent reviews check out MKBHD
talking about the 16 inch version and
our viewers on maxtech talking about the
16 inch that they bought and how they
absolutely love it once again thank you
to David for sending this out we're
gonna have links in the video
description if you guys want to pick one
of these up support a small business
with a very small team that genuinely
cares about quality and loves Max you
guys can go ahead and do that click that
Circle above to subscribe check out that
video right over there that's been Max
and I'll see you in the next one
[Music]
thank you